mike tyson fights roy jones jr eight
round exhibition belt that'll be
september 12th it's at nine eastern on
pay-per-view and
triller which is t-r-i-l-l-e-r
triller also streaming a docu-series
showcasing
the physical and mental preparation
leading up to the fight
exclusive to triller under hashtag
frontline battle trailer will drop two
episodes per week
nine eastern a.m eastern every friday
and saturday
mike tyson also kicks off shark week on
discovery channel
august 9th at 8 eastern as he goes
head-to-head with one of the ocean's top
predators
it's of course tyson versus jaws rumble
on the reef
reef with the famed ring announcer
michael buffer
calling all of the shots mike tyson
joining us on the program when did you
start getting the itch to get back into
the ring
hey listen um this is really funny
somebody had asked me my brother-in-law
asked me
he didn't want to ask me because i i was
um adamant about it many times people
ask me
will mike fight this guy who might fight
this guy for 20 million mike i fight
this guy for 50 or 30 million whatever
it was
and i always said no that's what i look
like i want to fight come on give me a
break all right give me
i'm not fighting and then one day he
asked me and i said
who do you want me to fight he said bob
sat
and i said well okay i know bob sack
he's a big strong guy but i said
what kind of rules would i have to fight
can i box him on the mark of the
queensbury
and he said one minute he called me said
yeah he'll do that i said okay i'll do
it
and um
we left that's where i started off and
then i started from fighting him and
then i thought
i'm i'm fighting from him i'm fighting
chuckle adele i'm fighting cheeky ortiz
now
now i'm fighting this guy then the king
are now it's
done i'm fighting roy jones now
that makes sense to you but it doesn't
make sense to me but it's where i'm at
now
well it probably didn't stop where
people kept waiting for you to
fight somebody because well you're
supposed to fight somebody
but at your age are you supposed to be
fighting somebody
i wouldn't fight nobody 10 years ago
i've seen i can do it for a better cause
a charity based cause
and um i feel great and i look great so
um why not
well then i heard that you said you
could knock out conor mcgregor in the
ring but would you get in the octagon
with conor mcgregor
mma i don't think i want to do that and
not
because conor might kick my ass but just
the fact that connor has the right to
step on my feet
and if anybody steps on my feet and i'm
tapping out he doesn't have to
wait wait so so that's the secret to
beating you is stepping on your toes
if he steps on my feet when we get out
the ring it's going to be a problem
then we're going to have to get some
police involved we have the lawyer
involved
but mike if peter mcneely had stepped on
your feet he might have been able to
beat you
absolutely
he did how would you fight
you if if i said this mike tyson was
going to fight
mike tyson 25 how would you do
so you know i'm lost for words
how do you fight a guy like that but the
intelligence though
of under like at your age and being wise
well maybe you'd be wise and not get in
the ring with a 25 year old mike tyson
no i i probably wouldn't but um he's
he's more of that 25 year old had
morphed into me
and so maybe if he ever understood who i
am now the 25 year old
maybe he wouldn't want to get in the
ring with me
how often did you see fear when you
walked into the ring
i see fear every day of my life but fear
from the opposition
i always you always feel fear from
opposition what's the purpose of even
fighting if that's not involved
but their face when you walk in and you
put fear on their face how often do you
think you saw that
in an opponent i didn't see fear i saw
intimidation
it's a big difference what's the
difference
fear is just it's an emotion that we
receive from god
for whatever purpose it is intimidation
is um
is an emotion that prevents you from
performing
at the highest point of your ability
and so that's intimidation to prevent
you from reaching your highest goal
what's the perfect punch feel like when
it lands
it doesn't feel like anything you don't
feel like you missed
really yes because
baseball players will talk about hitting
a home run and then they it feels like
nothing
yeah you don't feel you think you missed
them next thing you know you're out
there sleeping
did you ever feel sorry for an opponent
i wish
he didn't get in the situation that he
got into or something i wish he didn't
um
i think something bad didn't happen to
him that happened to him yeah
i don't like that who was that that you
you're talking about i don't know just
one guy i hit
um and he was down a little bit and i
hit him while he was down and i just
didn't like that
when i saw it when i was performing it
was great but when i saw it
it gave me bad feeling uh explain that
it says it's an exhibition fight with
roy jones
what does that mean in exhibition
exhibition i mean two people are
fighting it's not called a fight
but it's real pretty much yeah we're
throwing punches at each other
dan you know you've been in sports your
whole life and you know
not only in boxing but in sports even in
race car driving
anything there's always some unwritten
law and unwritten law that the
possibility you can die during training
or the actual game and listen
and we all know that because race car
drivers basketball players
wrestlers boxers we all seen it happen
since we were kids
and we want to be in that sport but we
all seen that some of us seem to happen
to our fathers
and we still want to do it and that's
who we
are and understand i can't explain why
and don't have me try to be an idiot
i just don't know why we're talking to
mike tyson he's gonna fight roy jones jr
eight round exhibition that'll be
september 12th at nine eastern
pay-per-view
and uh triller you know that your last
fight was what 15 years ago
yeah what do you remember about that i
remember i was i didn't really train i
wasn't excited about that fight
it was just um i don't know what it was
it was just a bill playing
really mundane day at the office
but it's hard you know you were such a
you're a walking business
and you know you have to fight and
people want you to fight and then you
how many times do you think you got in
the ring where you just said i just
i don't want to do this or i don't have
it well you do many times but in this
business
look um we're not gonna really get her
at least we believe we're not gonna get
hurt even if we
you know this is what we do that's what
we know how to do
when you went for revenge with larry
holmes was that
larry holmes beat muhammad ali and did
you said
you wanted revenge yeah it was october
2nd
1980. and why did it bother you so much
because at that time because that um had
drilled in my head that muhammad ali was
pretty much a god and was worthy of
worship
and stuff and so when i was um [ __ ]
i was probably 11 years old i saw
muhammad ali at spoiler reformatory
and um that's not one to fight
yeah i remember being the ringside and
ali came in in atlantic city i don't
know if you're fighting
uh spanx or uh frasier
i don't know but ali came in and i that
like the sea parted
there were all these people like it was
one of the most incredible entrances i
ever saw and it was just ali
and all these people started chanting
and cheering
and it was it was really emotional you
probably weren't even in the ring yet
but
when he came out i'll never ever forget
that i got goosebumps thinking about
that
i can tell that ollie has an impact on
you that
it makes you emotional
pretty much incredible
what when you start and you know the
science of boxing and you know the
history of boxing
uh and i always talk about ali was so
what i loved about ali
is you know these guys now who talk
trash like he was doing it saying i'm
gonna knock you out in this round
he had a strategy there like there's no
showman
like him bigger than that it's really
about world domination over yourself
what do you mean it's about conquering
yourself and conquering your fears
not really about conquering your
opponent
when did you conquer your fears i'm
still in that process of doing that i'm
not coming up here to never conquer
i'm a product of fear i'm from
brownsville brooklyn and if you don't
have fear there learn how to control the
deer
you're gonna have problems out of life
how much fun do you want to have with
this fight oh this is gonna be
i don't know my definition of fun
pokemon pocket broken jaw broken
[Laughter]
how often do people come up to you and
say that they would want to fight you
just on the street
when you run into people because every
time you see a champ you walk up and
then champ will
get ready act like he's going to throw a
little a couple punches well
i don't have that but people ask me on
occasion how do i knock out somebody how
do i throw a punch to knock someone out
what do i do if somebody attacks me like
this
and then it's ridiculous things that i
don't know what to do when they ask me
that stuff
why why don't you do a fantasy camp
where
you can get come in and get punched by
mike tyson like
people sign a waiver and they spend a
thousand dollars and they come in to
get punched by you i don't know stuff
like that are too mundane for me i like
to get right
[Laughter]
you you're done doing a lot of stuff
here we got shark week coming up too
you're involved in shark week oh listen
the sharks have men the sharks had me
shook man
what am i listen i'm from brownsville
brooklyn one of my
sharks man come on what am i doing what
are they trying to do
um coming what are they trying to
um make me civilized or something yeah
but
how did this idea come up that you're
going to fight a shark listen oh you you
don't want to hit it
yes i do listen you don't want to hit it
all right you want to hear this
but listen dana white ufc
president thought he was doing me a
favor mike i don't want you to fight
mike
just do a couple of these games and for
you you gotta be straight don't worry
about fighting
i i get these gigs he wants he care
about me fighting
roy jones he wants me to go flu with
sharks do you care about me
fighting with roy jones do you
understand that that makes
he's worried about me but he give me a
kick swimming with
oh tell me sharks does that look please
i'm like whoa god he cares a lot
yeah i don't think dana white cares
about you that much mike if he's willing
to let you fight a shark
right like i would fight roy jones jr
and i have no business being in the ring
and that's what i told my wife
i said baby dana really cares about our
family
he has me fighting sharks wow
like that who needs enemies right have
you
have your kids seen you fight
not my younger kid now
they're going to see this fight right i
want them to
they're going to come with me to the
fight i hope and what happened with uh
the possibility of fighting holyfield
i don't know um that's on the table
but um i guess the people wanted roy
i guess would you ever come back for
real
hey listen i never thought about that
but listen this is fun
let's see how many charities we can help
how many people we can help and let's
see how long i'll be around let's see
how long i can hold up this stuff looks
pretty good i feel pretty good
i've been in that spot man it's ready
this is awesome man you look good
i mean you looked you looked i'm so
awesome
i'm sorry no no i was complimenting you
on looking good so people are saying
he's too old to do this he's gonna make
whatever nothing in the world you asked
george foreman he said oh man if i was
mike and roy i wouldn't do this that's a
joy said right
but you asked him when he was on his
journey to become come back a champion
everything they were saying they're
making fun of them this is too old
and when you really think about all
that's worth accomplishing your goal
being made to fool that laugh that
it's worth it would you fight tyson fury
it's a possibility for what charity yeah
how many barriers we can help yeah i'll
fight them i'll fight anybody for that
it's not really um it's not based on
money the money is only based on what we
can do with it pretty much not on
any kind of self-granddizement anything
when uh they make the movie on your life
who's going to play you
i don't know give me an idea
so jamie foxx how about tom cruise
[Laughter]
i don't know how good a boxer is but
sure why not
hold on hey it's in the works we're
talking about it
jamie looks really good for the part
they talking about using anti-aging with
them as well
like they did an irishman yeah we want
to see what happens i'm just i'm very
excited
and um it's gonna be interesting it's
gonna be interesting
how do you think jamie would do in the
ring
if he's properly taught i think he'd do
well
how do you think stallone looked in
rocky like was there a rocky movie where
you thought stone looked like
he could have held him held his own in
the ring as a as a
some kind of contender that
that wasn't based on appearances and all
that stuff
rocky was based on intestinal fortitude
hard work determination the desire to
overcome adversity that's what that was
based on
so that makes that next to raising bull
the greatest boxing movie in the world
yeah
who do you want to be conglomerate of
fight inspiration
so that's why he supersedes everyone
else but when you talk about
the raging bull that's a real person
overcoming those odds who do you think
look more realistic
de niro in the ring or stallone
daenerys looked really good they never
looked good and sort of rocky like they
both look good i was both entertained by
both of them
i'd like to see them get in the ring
against each other they did that but not
for real but they did that in the movie
oh that's right that movie wasn't any
good yeah you're right i'd like to see
it for real
but listen though it's so interesting
you can't have people that never really
participated in boxing and try to do
that for real because
it's so easy to get hurt one little slug
and boom i think you got a blood cloth
[Laughter]
all right i'd say good luck against uh
roy jones jr but more importantly good
luck against the shark mike i'm i'm
worried you might lose a limb here
man listen i can't tell you uh man
that's listen people like
with friends in my corner who needs
enemies you know
you look great you sound great i hope
you have some fun and you raise some
money and uh
you know that maybe this is the first of
uh a few for you
this thing turns out the way i
anticipated well thank you mike great to
talk to you
my friend god bless mike tyson